- I would go to school crying every day,
like literally crying.
- I never emotionally
lost my s--- that hard before.
- Oh.
(mellow music)
Take one.
(clapping)
So would you be okay to
answer a couple of questions?
So would you be down to answer
like a couple of questions?
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course, hold on,
let me just put on my shades
'cause I wanna, if it's that personal
I don't wanna start crying on the camera.
- What's the most painful
thing someone has said to you?
Who's one stranger you still remember?
- Do you have any talent?
- Do I have any talents?
First of all, be kinda easy.
Can you just tell us a
little bit about yourself?
- I'm a really big nerd.
I gotta 3D printer in my room
and I got a bunch of built
in like stuff over here,
like bunch of tools, I have
like a 200 piece tool set.
- So what's like your, what's your dream,
what do you wanna do man?
- Mechanical engineering.
- Okay, sounds like
you're on the right track.
- Yeah, hopefully.
- Who's one stranger you still remember?
This could be someone
you met once, years ago,
or like someone who
ended up being a friend.
But that first impact, like,
has really stuck with you.
- When you said that, the
first thing that came to mind
was when I went camping
and there was this,
there were these two kids on
bikes that started bullying me.
And they just rolled their bikes around
and then every time they came
by they'd like throw s--- at me.
And like, like it would really like f-----.
And then after a few
days, I was just like,
yo, you guys wanna play man
hunt with me and my cousins?
And they were like, sure,
and then we became really good friends.
- So you basically turned your
bullies into your friends?
- Exactly, by playing man hunt with them.
- They were obviously
hurting your feelings right?
What made you want to
like reach out to them
and ask them if they
wanted to play with you?
- I don't know, I've
always had the personality
where I just don't like,
like things just don't get to me.
The kids throwing at me, I'll
just like look at them like,
you know, what the hell?
Hey, you guys wanna play some man hunt?
And they were just like, yeah sure, okay.
And I don't hold grudges at all, like,
it's not something I do.
- Who was one stranger you still remember?
- I know this one, like,
off the top of my head.
- Really?
- So, I remember I was in eighth grade
and I just moved from
Connecticut to Miami,
where Miami but.
I'm a senior, so that
was a couple of years ago
but I was very sad.
I literally lost all my friends,
like I didn't have no friends.
It was hard as f---.
I really, I would go to
school crying every day,
like 20 minutes before class would start,
I would go to the
bathroom and start crying.
People started laughing at me
and like you know, whatever.
I dunno, it was just so hard emotionally.
So I kept saying to myself,
and that was the problem,
I just kept saying like, I'm sad, I'm sad,
Like I would say that every day.
And I remember at lunch one
time, this one kid was like,
listen, at the end of
the day we're all like,
whatever you want your
life to be, it can be that.
If you wanna be sad
every day, then be sad.
If you wanna be happy every day,
if you're gonna tell yourself
that you're gonna be happy
every day, then you'll be happy.
I had no hope and I guess it
was the only thing I had left
to just try, 'cause I tried everything.
So, I tried it and it worked.
It started working, I
literally started feeling good
and it was awesome.
- What's the most painful
thing someone has said to you?
- That I'll, like, like
I will never be nothing.
Like, there was like, you
will never be nothing,
you'll never be successful in life.
And I was like, that was kinda hurtful.
It caught me off guard.
When me being me, like I was like,
I don't give a f--- what they
say, I'm gonna do me,
my grades is up there,
my style's up there like,
it was painful but I like, I got over it.
- So do you have advice for other people
who maybe have heard the same words
but unlike you, they kinda
let it get them down?
- I mean, I've been through a lot.
So it's like, I'd like to
tell people just don't listen
to that bad stuff.
Like, if food make you happy, go eat,
if shopping make people
happy then go spend a bag,
like just pos up.
Like you don't, don't take
those words and run with it
because if you run with it
then it's going to damage you
and you're just gonna keep believing
that you're gonna be nothing.
You just won't be successful if you let
that replay in your head.
- Hello.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Can you speak Spanish?
- I don't, I wish.
Do you understand everything
I'm saying though, right?
- No, I.
- So do you want to try to
talk or do you wanna skip?
I'm a YouTuber, is it okay
with you that I'm recording?
- Are you YouTuber?
- Yeah.
- Oh my god.
- You're a YouTuber too?
(laughing)
Are you recording this?
- Yep.
- You are?
- I am historically YouTuber.
Do you have any talent?
- Do I have any talents?
- Yeah.
- I can clap with one hand.
Like one hand.
(clapping)
- Bye.
- No, no, no, no.
- Thank you.
- Oh okay, okay, okay.
- No, that's my talent, that's my talent.
My talent, I clap with one hand.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- That's my talent and then
also have you seen this,
have you seen this trick?
This one, how you, wait up.
- Oh, okay, okay.
(laughing)
Okay, thank you, thank you
thank you for your time.
- Thank you for your time as well.
I wish.
- Me, my English.
- Your English is better
than my Spanish, so.
- Okay.
- All right, thank you, bye.
- Thank you.
- Is there like an interesting fact,
like a unique fact about you
that most people don't know?
- That I have a good singing voice.
- You have a good singing voice?
Why doesn't anyone know about it?
You just, are you just too shy
to like maybe tell people or?
- Yeah.
Would you be down to sing right now?
- Can you tell me a song to sing.
- Sing any song you know.
♪ Just another one champion sound ♪
♪ Me and Estelle about to get down ♪
♪ Who the hottest in the world right now ♪
♪ Just touched down in London town ♪
(clapping)
Oh my god.
- You're so good.
If I had a good voice, I'd
be singing all the time.
What's the most painful thing
someone has said to you?
- They have called me a thot before.
- A what?
- A thot.
- Out of everything painful
that you've ever heard,
why do you think that
one hurts you the most?
- Because I don't think that's true.
I've been trying to find someone great
to have a relationship
with for like a few years.
But it never worked out so
because of that people
like to call me that.
Not many people, but
it's not nice you know.
Because I was trying to find
happiness, not be called thot.
- Who's one stranger you still remember?
- I mean, I saw this cute
guy on a bike yesterday.
(laughing)
- What's the most painful
thing you've been told?
- Been told?
- Yeah.
- Probably when my ex, well my now ex,
when we were dating at the time.
She's like, can we go
out to my car real quick,
before I bring you home.
Like, yeah sure.
And then she started crying
and then she was like,
I'm sorry to say this
but we need to break up.
I never emotionally lost
my s--- that hard before.
- Oh.
- 'Cause I loved her and
I have never expected us
to ever break up 'cause
we, like she always told me
and I've always said it back, like,
we're not gonna break
up, like we're forever.
We were together for two years.
- It was nice meeting you,
thanks for answering my questions.
- No problem.
Thank you so much for
asking me these questions.
- Of course.
- Thank you, it was nice meeting you.
- You too, bye.
What's your name on YouTube?
Okay, here's my name.
- Oh my god, oh my god.
You're quite famous.
- [Thoraya] No.
- Really, yeah.
- One million, more.
- I'm sorry, god, no, you're, oh my god.
- Oh, you got a million.. you got, oh, period, period. sis, yes.
- So you, holy s----, holy s---- dawg you have
1.13 million subscribers.
Yo, can you hep me out?
- [Thoraya] Yep.
Yeah, so, if I put up this video,
I'll include your YouTube channel.
- Hell yeah.
- So,
- Subscribe.
- [Thoraya] Thank you.
I'm gonna subscribe to
you too, hang on, let me.
What's your YouTube channel?
- Oh, appreciate that.
It's called Chris, it's one series
- Like the way you like presented yourself
and the way you like
you talked, I was like,
oh, she probably has like
a few thousand subscribers,
not a million.
Do you have the plaque yet?
- [Thoraya] I do, yeah, I just got it.
- Can I see it?
Oh my god, I wanna see it so badly.
- Is that your merch, the be kind?
- It is, yeah, do you want one?
- Please, what?
- But you have to ask your
parents first, you can't,
we can't do it without your
parents permission, okay.
- I will ask, I'm sure she'll say yes.
- Okay, cool.
- I'm literally.
- Oh god, no.
Okay, how do we skip?
I don't even know how to skip on here.
(laughing)
Can you tell that I'm red?
'Cause I am.
I'm sweaty, why am I wearing a sweater?
Okay, how to skip on Omegle.